ها البيبي جنني
نِنَّنا يَا نُونُو يَا نُونُو نِنَّنا يَا نُونُو
يَتَسَلَّق فَوْقَ الكَنَبَةْ نونو
يَقْفِزْ لِلأَعْلَى لَعِبَا نونو
يَجْرِى بَابَا يُنْقِذُهُ نونو
يَضْحَكْ هَاهَاهَا بَبَّا
يَتَسَلَّلُ نَحْوَ الدُّولاَبْ
يَسْحَبُ بِيَدَيْهِ الأَثْوَابْ
يُلْقِيهَا وَيَنَامُ عَلَيْهَا
وَيُبَعْثِرُ كُلَّ الأَلْعَابْ
ها البيبي جنني
نِنَّنا يَا نُونُو يَا نُونُو نِنَّنا يَا نُونُو
يَجْذِبُ لِيَجُرَّ السِّتَارَةْ نونو
يَحْبُوْ لِيُقَلِّدَ سَيَّارَةْ نونو
وَيُطَارِدُ بِالصَّالَةِ قِطَّةْ نونو
مَامَا تُرَاقِبَهُ مُحْتَارَةْ
يَحْبُو فِي كُلِّ الأَرْجَاءْ
وَيُتَمْتِمُ دَاا دَادا دَاااءْ
يَسْحَبُ مِنْ فَوْقَ الطَّاوِلَةِ
مَفْرَشَهَا فَيَرْمِى الأَشْيَاءْ
نونو
أوه
تَحْمِلُهُ مَامَا تُهَزْهِزُهُ
وَنُغَنِّي حَتَى نُشَجِّعَهُ
كَي يَنْعَسْ لَحْظَة وَيَنَام
لَا نصْدِرُ صَوْتًا يُزْعِجُهُ
نُونُو نُونُو مَا أَحْلَاه
فِى المَنْزِلِ مَرَحٌ وَحَيَاهْ
لَوْ يِهْدَأْ سَاعَةْ وَيَنَامْ
نَشْتَاقُ لِيَصْحُو لِنَرَاهْ
ها البِيبِي مَا أَحْلَاه
نِنَّنا يَا نُونُو يَا نُونُو  نِنَّنا يَا نُونُو